ما هي البحار السبعة من العملات المشفرة
الفاسدة المخبأة لمجرمي كروكس المحتالين في
الكرنفال وأخيراً
كان تشيكوسلوفاكيا على المنصة
الآن كان من المفترض أن أجادله قبل عام
هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة في اللحظة الأخيرة
قرر الهروب لم يكن يريد  أن أكون
في نفس المنصة التي
تخمنها قبل عامين من مناقشة الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة Arturay بشأن
bitmax وبعد أسبوع تم
اتهامه وانتهى به المطاف في السجن لأنني كتبت أنه
كان محتالًا
في مقعدك كان من المفترض أن يكون هنا
اليوم فقط كيفن ليري  كان اختراق مدفوع الأجر
لـ FTX لأسباب وجيهة ، وآمل أن
تتخلص CNBC منه للأسف ،
هذا نظام بيئي فاسد تمامًا
للأسف ، وأعتقد أن
الدرس المستفاد من الأسابيع القليلة الماضية هو أن هؤلاء
الأشخاص يجب أن يكونوا خارج هنا